exploded axonometrics are some of the
most beautiful things that you can
create
in your career as an architect they
portray a lot of detail
in a very artistic way today i'm going
to show you exactly how to create one of
the best
axon and metrics you can in arcade25
what's going on guys my name is david
thomas and welcome back to the channel
if you're new here firstly thank you so
much for joining me
on this channel we talk all things
technology and architecture
it's my purpose here to share as much
valuable architecture knowledge
with you guys as i possibly can that
usually comes in the form of archived
tutorials
app reviews or innovative technology i
do my best
to share as much as i possibly can
because i know how secretive
the architecture industry is so today
we're talking about axonometrics
and how to create some very beautiful
very simple axonometrics in arcade 25.
before we turn around to these two
screens i want you guys to simply drop a
comment down below
and let me know what resources you are
really lacking
are you looking for things like new
templates are you looking for things
like checklists and guides are you
looking for things to help you with
photoshop or illustrator
what are you looking for to help you
better yourself as an architecture
student
or as an architect i really want to know
what resources
you guys need so please let me know in
the comments down below and let's get
started
welcome back to another tutorial today
guys today we're starting with the
australian select template because
that's what's available to me
feel free to start with whatever is
available to you we're going to be
creating an axon and metric
that is so simple so clean and yet so
beautiful
that can be done and i'm hoping under
five minutes
so let's get started by just simply
creating the basic shell of what we're
going to do
we're going to create a small little
bathroom and produce an axo from that
so let's start by using our wall tool
with the wall tool we always want to
make sure
all our layers are correct so external
walls outside face
what kind of wall we're using again
doesn't really to matter in this case
i'm just going to go stud petition now
let's start by clicking once in the
center of the page
holding shift and pressing the d button
i'm going to go
2 meters for the width of the bathroom
i'm going to go about
5 meters for the length and i'm going to
finish it off
in a nice perfect square now we're going
to start by opening up our objects tool
looking for a toilet is one of the
easiest things to start with
so water closet 25 here we go
let's say we want a wall mounted unit
and we want a nice one
let's say something like that doesn't
really matter
we look at it in 3d we want that
in-wall cistern and we like these
buttons those buttons are quite nice
so let's leave it as it is and that's
basically all we have to do for the
toilet we're just going to change
the object layer as well we'll just call
it mep plumbing for now
clicking ok dropping our toilet in i'm
going to duplicate that toilet by
pressing ctrl
d and then the control button again
holding shift
will align it perfectly so now we're
going to press command t
open back up our object settings we're
going to type in shower
let's use cabin shower or shower cabin
25
looking at it in 3d we most likely want
to just have
one wall activated so if we go to this
one it'll automatically change our
shower head to a rain head
coming back to our cabin type we
probably want a custom cabin
we want it to be two meters long we want
it to be about a meter wide i'm not
going to go into too many settings here
it's more so about that axo so adjust
these settings however you see
fit i don't want a tray because i don't
like the tray
and then i'm just going to change that
to black
so again just clicking okay now we're
going to rotate this around by
pressing ctrl e holding shift again
rotating at 90 degrees control m will
allow us to flip it the opposite way
so now our shower is at the top and then
we can move our toilet a little bit
closer
okay so let's copy that toilet across
once more command t
and go to vanity basins we're going to
use this multi basin
for today again just creating something
simple to show the purposes of
that axonometric we're going to remove
all of these
change the thickness to 300 change the
depth to 200 and
make it a rectangle probably only need
two basins in this instance
and we can change our tap styles we can
do whatever we like
it doesn't really matter too much so
i'll change the lines to black
drop it in and place it in our
bathroom so now our bathroom is probably
too big i'll move that
450 millimeters away from the center of
that toilet
ungroup by pressing ct alt g
and then control d again to move
that wall in lastly i'm going to press
command
i to link all those walls together and
jump back into 3d to see what we've got
so at the moment in 3d
we have our shower screen with our rain
head
shower we have a grab rail at the back
which we probably don't need
so i'm just going to quickly jump in
here and
turn that grab rail off so that grab
rail is now gone we have our toilet
we have our vanity basin overall we have
the beginnings of
an axonometric there's a lot of things
missing here to make it quite nice
first of all i want to copy this vanity
basin over
and just introduce a mirror so by going
mirror 25 we have this mirror here i'm
simply going to
drag it and drop it into this wall and
adjust it in 3d to see if it works for
me
so i think that mirror is pretty much
good it's going to be quite large
we'll drag it in line with the top of
that
and then we're simply just going to
adjust the settings a little bit more we
don't want it to be that thick let's
make it 20 mil
thick now what you'll notice is it's
quite ugly it's quite
not artistic at all especially when you
want an axonometric
so what we'll do is select all our walls
pressing alt
g to activate our group press command
t and then we're going to change the
external
wall structure to tiles let's use tiles
150 by 150 and press
ok so we have very small tiles on the
wall
but it sets the standard we're going to
come back to our floor plan
and simply draw a slab below so
if we select our slab we can use all
sorts of different things
let's go to this structural concrete
with tile finish
and let's draw it from edge to edge
now coming back into our 3d we'll see
we've drawn our
tiles below all the way our walls and
we've got
our walls completely surrounded in tiles
so floor to ceiling tiles
in this model now this is where it gets
a little bit different a little bit
tricky and
we really want to be able to create the
best axonometric possible
so what we're going to do is actually
change a few materials and create
something new so let's start by going
into our surfaces panel at the top
if you don't have this activated come to
window
toolbars attributes and that will
activate this palette here
let's start by opening our surfaces
palette and we're going to replicate
glass so let's find glass
blue perfect so we're going to use this
glass blue and adjust
this material here to be a nice
tranquil blue and really beautiful light
blue
that's going to be appealing in your
accent metrics so
how do we do that let's start by
adjusting some of these settings
feel free to pause it anytime in this
video and screenshot it as much as you
need to make sure your settings match
what mine are so first let's start by
changing the surface color
my surface colour is defaulted here
that's the blue we're going to be using
i've created it before
i've adjusted it i've used it i like it
we might even change it just a little
bit
to there we go just the tiniest tiniest
little bit
so 132 240 215
pressing okay changes our surface color
next we want to adjust our transparency
all the way to 100
and this as well all the way to 100 we
want to keep our emissions at zero
and 100 100 73
i don't recommend this always for glass
it is just for this
specific tutorial use the regular glass
object for your windows and things like
that
however i'm just finding that these
settings work really really well now we
can click
ok and jump across to
our fields so by default you have 25
50 and 70 what we want to do is
go new and create a simple
10 transparent fill clicking okay
simply changing that to 10 and going
okay
now probably should have done that
before so we'll jump back to our
surfaces
go to our glass and change our
background fill
to 10 percent now we click ok
and we want to start changing some of
the materials
in this model here so let's open up our
shower
go to our material settings and
simply just change our cabin glass to
the glass blue we just created it'll
change the material of
that cabin and then we also want to
change the material
off this mirror that we've created as
well so we'll change the glass from
glass
to glass blue and click ok now we want
to come back into our floor plan we want
to get our marquee tool
we want to have the single floor
selection we want to marquee the outside
of those two walls and
the inside of these two walls right
click
show marquee in 3d so
now what we've effectively created is a
3d
marquee of that space removing those two
walls so we can see internally and
actually look at what we're trying to
create as an axo so what we want to do
is quickly just extend our screen
move it into the crop zone and find
this detailed shading selection we want
to
click on this 3d styles which will open
up
our 3d styles window so what we're going
to start by doing is duplicating these
technical drawings so let's go
new technical drawings we'll just rename
it to
axo and then click ok
what we want to do is repeat these
settings exactly as i have them
so transparency we keep on but we reduce
it to hidden line
we don't want a monochromatic model and
we want to change our sky
from blue to white so both areas are
nice and white
we want as in photo rending rendering
activated and we also want our vertical
hatching activated
we don't want our sun shadows on we
don't need them so we're going to turn
those off
and we're going to reduce all of these
lines here to 1.
so now by clicking ok you're going to
see our entire
model change so now we're significantly
closer to getting this to exactly how we
want it
what we have to do is change the actual
line types of these objects so they
aren't pink and green
we want them all to be black lines so
we're coming into our settings going to
the floor plan and section overrides
and simply just making all the lines
black
to make them stand out properly and
there we go so far we have our
axonometric set up
it's looking really really nice and but
it's not an axonometric at all yet it's
still a perspective view
so there's only one real final step now
before we finish
off this axonometric and that's simply
going
into view 3d options
3d projection settings and we're going
to go parallel projections
axonometric change it to our isometric
axonometry and it doesn't really matter
about the sun position at all
clicking ok if i double click my scroll
wheel
it's going to bring up that axonometric
so if you wanted to go ahead and change
the tiles
to make them bigger or larger you can do
that very quickly and
very easily so let's change these wall
tiles here
to a 300 by 300 pattern we can do that
by coming into here
finding our grid 15 by 15 that was
created
and simply let's just change that to 300
by
600. if i click ok you'll see those
tiles instantly change
to bigger tiles there's a much better
way of doing that but i just simply
wanted to demonstrate
the ease and effectiveness of that axo
and that's pretty much all there is to
this axonometric it is a very simple
process
once you set up these layers and you
keep the new object you keep this
new 3d view you can basically create one
of these axonometrics by marking
any one of your bathroom designs if you
want to take it even further you can put
a channel drain along
the side of that glass screen and maybe
a floor waist
in underneath this vanity basin to make
it even more realistic
and you can manipulate it even more if
you wanted to turn it into an exploded
axonometric
you can simply zoom out click on one of
the objects
drag it up as far as you need to drag
out
each individual item and place them
in perfectly arranged spaces then all
you would do
is save that 3d view and draw some 2d
lines
in your layout book to make that an
exploded axonometric
incredibly simple incredibly quick and
definitely something that more people
should be doing anyway that's all for me
today guys thank you so much for
watching i hope you enjoyed the video
i hope you learned something very quick
and very easy in this monday's tutorial
it was not very hard a little bit of
setup but once you've got it going
it is so easy if you enjoyed it make
sure you smash that subscribe button
down below and don't forget about the
like button
the like button genuinely helps this
video grow with the youtube algorithm
and helps this channel grow
so i'd appreciate it if you smash the
subscribe button and smash the like
button
and like always i'll see you next monday